EÉmilie Nicolas, Michel C. Auge,
ChChristian Dufour, bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - On le savait, le principal
inintéressé la confirmait, je vs
lele montre comment, Monsieur
LeLegault a annoncé dimanche tot
çaça est parti.
- - Bonjour tout le monde!
J'J'ai le plaisir de vous annonr
quque la campagne électorale va
êêtre déclenchée officiellement
lele 28 août prochain.
- - Voilà, en fait, vous pourriz
meme dire qu'elle est déjà
dédéclenchée, que dans fond on a
enen parler dans un instant
d'd'ailleurs, il y a des
enengagements très précis.
MiMichel C. Auger, on le disait
hihier, c'est quand même inusit,
c'c'est parti sans être parti.
- - Oui, c'est inévitable, on le
savait, que ce soit déclenché ce
didimanche ou ce samedi, ça ne
chchange pas grand-chose.
CeCe qu'il faudrait pour la
prprochaine fois, penser par
exexemple, est-ce qu'on devrait
papas avoir un mécanisme de
lilimitation des dépenses
élélectorales auprès électorale
avavant la campagne.
C'C'est un autre débat et il se
fefera après les élections.
- - Oui.
PaPar ce que on voit excéder le
trtrain, la campagne était lance
avavant, bien sûr, lassé des
anannonces, des slogans, tout et
llà.
C'C'est surréaliste de voir qu'n
esest en train de commenter des
prpromesses électorales d'une
cacampagne électorale n'est pas
cocommencée officiellement.
C'C'est une belle illustration,n
prprojet de réforme qui est très
bebeau sur papier.
LeLe projet de loi des électionà
dadate fixe, la plupart est
d'd'accord avec ça, sauf que çaa
eueu des effets pervers majeurs.
CeCette notion pour l'avenir etl
fafaudra la changer ça ne marche
papas.
OnOn voulait un système...
ququelqu'un m'a dit qu'on voulat
ququ'on aimait le système avant.
- - Émilie.
- - C'est sûr qu'il y a des
inintervenants, il y avait des
grgros inconvénients avec l'ancn
sysystème.
LaLa question est de savoir si n
pepeut régler ses inconvénients.
BeBeaucoup d'observateurs sont
d'd'accord sur le fait que si on
enencadre mieux les dépenses
élélectorales, ça irait mieux.
IlIl y a aussi la réalité qu'ona
unun gouvernement qui dépense en
pupublicité à des niveaux recors
dedepuis bien avant, la dernière
sesemaine aussi.
CÇa amène des partis
d'd'opposition... ça amène un
cycycle de dépenses où chacun
essasaie de mettre son modèle
avavant.
IlIl y a des pratiques sont peu-
êêtre douteuses sur le plan
ététique est fofolle à observer.
CÇa reste qu'en période estival,
mmême si les personnes font...
unune grande partie des gens ne
sosont pas légaux aussi.
- - Le principal problème...
- - Oui Michel C. Auger, allez-.
- - Le principal problème, les
ininconvénients délaissés le
prpremier ministre de décider àa
guguise la date élections était
ininfiniment plus grave.
- - On pourra en discuter plus
plplus tôt.
- - Pas trop non.
- - Annonce environnementale
auaujourd'hui de la part de
MoMonsieur Legault, un fond bleu
popour protéger rivières, lacs
etetc.
OuOu l'industrie participerait
bebeaucoup.
OnOn écoute un extrait de Monsir
LeLegault.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT, chef,
CoCoalition avenir Québec
- - J'ose dire qu'il y a jamais
unun gouvernement au Québec quin
a a fait autant pour lutter cone
leles changements climatiques.
PuPuis jusqu'à ce jour, malgré
leles promesses de certains,
eheh bien, il y a aucun parti
popolitique qui a un plan chiff.
DoDonc, on peut bien pelleter
dedes nuages, faire des beaux
didiscours, mais il y a aucun
paparti politique qui a un plan
chchiffré pour réduire les GES.
- - Ça, c'était le message que
MoMonsieur Legault voulait lancr
enen début de campagne.
ChChristian, les arrêtés me
dédépeignent comme quelqu'un qui
n'n'aime pas ou qui sous-estimet
leles questions environnementals
etet c'est ce qu'on voulait
enenvoyer le message.
- - Il est sur la défensive, cee
sosont pas les plus
enenvironnementalistes de tous,
mamais en même temps son discous
sese tient à quelque part.
IlIl profite de la situation
paparticulière du Québec.
AuAu Québec, il y a une partie
imimportante de la population qi
onont des convictions
enenvironnementalistes, ou la
lulutte contre les changements
clclimatiques très fortes.
IlIl profite d'une énergie qui a
seses propres de l'énergie
hyhydroélectrique.
OnOn ne pollue pas tant que ça,l
prprofite de ça parce qu'il faut
prprofiter de cette situation-là
alalors que d'autres ne se...
MoMonsieur Legault, profite de a
sisituation très spécifique du
QuQuébec où il y a les idéologis
etet les convictions d'une part,
etet le Québec est favorisé pare
cacannabis lance on se compare u
rereste Canadada, on est bien p.
- - Émilie et Michel C. Auger,
l'l'eau, et ça revient dans chae
cacampagne, qu'on demande des
reredevances plus élevées, il
totouche un air sensible Michel
ququand même.
- - Il touche un air sensible ms
enen même temps, et on a raison,
onon a beaucoup joué sur
l'l'hydroélectricité, une décisn
ququi a été prise il y a plusies
dédécennies, c'est ça qui nous
dodonne un bon bilan.
NoNotre véritable problème
acactuellement ce n'est pas
mamauvais ce qu'il propose, mais
cece n'est pas l'eau, sinon cibe
dede gaz à effet de serre.
C'C'est là où entraîne la pâte.
C'C'est là qu'on voit que même
dadans les situations extrêêmes
cocomme La fonderie Horne, avec
leles normes très sérieuses, ce
n'n'est pas une mauvaise annonc,
c'c'est une bonne chose.
MaMais il n'y a pas une grande
memenace à l'eau actuellement au
QuQuébec.
CeCe n'est pas là que le bât
blblesse pour le bilan énergétie
etet environnemental du Québec.
- - Très bien, Émilie un petit t
susur l'eau et sur ce que a fait
etet à vous l'envoyer un message
MoMonsieur Legault aujourd'hui?
- - Je pense qu'avec les quatre
anans de mandats qui ont été déà
étété effectués, les gens sont
coconvaincus ou pas convaincus e
lala foi environnementaliste de
MoMonsieur Legault, ce n'est pas
l'l'annonce d'aujourd'hui qui va
chchanger ça.
JeJe pense aussi que justement
c'c'est un dossier qui a été
crcritiqué, je disais plutôt que
enen période électorale dans
l'l'été, il y a beaucoup de gens
ququi ne portent pas attention à
cece qui se passe.
C'C'est une bonne chose du
gogouvernement Legault de faire
cecette annonce, que ça passe ss
lala table, mais qu'on n'a pas
bebeaucoup de gens qui puissent
rérépondre critiquer.
CeCe n'est pas que le plan est i
épépouvantable, c'est l'ensemble
dedes sauts de choses sur le pln
enenvironnemental sont difficils
àà répondre.
DoDonc, autant commencer
mamaintenant pendant qu'il y a s
bebeaucoup de gens qui écoutent,
jeje comprends tout à fait la
ststratégie derrière ça.
- - Vous dites pas qu'il voulait
s's'en débarrasser mais presque.
- - Un peu, je pense que oui.
- - On va écouter Gabriel Nadeau
DuDubois, et Paul St-Pierre
PlPlamondon qui eux aussi sont
alallés d'engagement à saveur
enenvironnementale.
OnOn voit que c'est un thème qui
vava revenir.
EÉvidemment comment faire
auautrement.
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
paparlementaire, Québec solidaie
- - Les gens, ils veulent faire
leleur part pour la planète,
ilils savent que les changements
clclimatiques, c'est déjà
cocommencé. Mais s'ils ont pas
d'd'alternative, ils sont
imimpuissants. Nous, on va
leleur redonner des solutions,
dedes options, pour pouvoir fai,
dadans leur quotidien,
lele choix écologique.
PAPAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chchef, Parti québécois
- - En s'en allant vers
leles transports collectifs avec
lala passe climat, non seulement
onon fait des économies sur une
babase individuelle - donc,
onon a plus d'argent dans
nonotre poche -, mais on fait
égégalement des économies sur
lele plan de l'État parce que
c'c'est une façon beaucoup plus
inintelligente de se déplacer,
susur le plan des coûts. Mais
évévidemment, la raison principe
dede cette mesure-là, c'est
nonotre volonté de faire face
auaux changements climatiques.
- - Rapidement, sur cette
prproposition de Paul Saint-Piee
PlPlamondon 365 $ une passe
ununiverselle pour prendre le
trtransport en commun un peu
papartout au Québec.
MiMichel C. Auger, c'est
iningénieux?
- - C'est une bonne idée, le
prproblème c'est évidemment dans
lala réalisation.
SiSi vous avez une passe qui vos
pepermet à 20 $ par jour de tous
leles autobus Québec et que vous
êêtes obligé de faire un
trtransfert et que vous attendez
4040 minutes pour l'autre autob,
çaça ne marchera pas.
IlIl a beaucoup de travail à
fafaire, des coordinations.
LeLes gens à Montréal, ne
cocomprennent pas pourquoi le
lalangage n'est pas là-dedans,
c'c'est compliqué.
EtEt coordonner les autobus et e
mémétro pour que les gens
enentendent moins possible surtt
enen région plus éloignée, c'est
trtrès compliqué.
AlAlors, ça marche si on fait
l'l'autre.
C'C'est un prérequis qu'on est n
sysystème intégré de transport.
- - On voit qu'on cherche des
fafaçons originales pour
enencourager le transport en
cocommun.
EÉmilie?
- - C'est vraiment dans les
dédétails, c'est une bonne idée
susur le principe, après c'est e
reregarder; et ce que les gens i
prprennent les transports en
cocommun, est-ce qu'il prenait
l'l'automobile avant où il s'est
plplacé déplacer déjà en transpt
enen commun ou avec d'autres tys
dede mobilité?
OnOn a vu dans d'autres villes,n
ararrière par exemple, ça crée n
acachalandage plus grand qui
pepermet d'augmenter les horair,
ceceux à quoi Michel fait
alallusion.
IlIl faut voir plus de données
coconcrètes pour comprendre qui
esest ciblé par un programme coe
çaça, si c'est des gens qui se
dédéplacent rapidement, souvent
d'd'une région à l'autre, ces gs
pepeuvent en profiter, mais este
quque c'est démographiquement
asassez gros pour faire des
chchangements climatiques.
JeJe n'ai pas les réponses dans
leles jeux comme ça.
- - Christian, un petit mot.
- - Ça fait un petit peu gadget,
aiaimant les politiciens, ça n'a
papas beaucoup de crédibilité.
IlIl ne prendra pas le pouvoir e
totoute façon.
OnOn ne va pas disserter pendant
unune demi-heure là-dessus.
- - La campagne électorale, mmêe
sisi les parties ne prennent pas
lele pouvoir, et le prochain que
jeje vais vous parler, Monsieur
DuDuhaime, qui parle du 3e lien,
s's'il y a un sujet qui va pas
bebeaucoup de départ et l'aspect
enenvironnemental de la chose, u
niniveau des voitures etc.
LeLe développement urbain, c'est
lele 3e lien.
EtEt le parti conservateur du
QuQuébec, Monsieur Duhaime a
prproposé un pont qui remplacert
leles pilons de Hydro-Québec, pr
l'l'île d'Orléans et en faire ue
papartie vers le sud. Michel C.
AuAuger, c'est intéressant, le e
lilien va cristalliser toutes ls
didifférences des parties, et on
vava vouloir se démarquer.
- - Est-ce qu'il y a quelque che
dede plus clivant auprès
papatrimonial que l'île d'orléa?
FaFaire un pont sur l'île
d'd'Orléans, ça va était éviden,
leles envoyer passionnés.
EtEt peu de gens qui vont être
papassionnés aussi.
LeLe problème n'est pas là, le
prproblème est qu'il faut penser
lele passage du fleuve à Québec
d'd'une autre façon.
EsEst-ce un tunnel, le tunnel va
cocoûter très cher, les jambons
l'l'ont déjà dit, il va favorisr
l'l'étalement urbain.
EsEst-ce que plus à l'Est ça rèe
lele problème?
JeJe ne crois pas.
IlIl faut regarder l'ensemble du
dodossier et ne pas le faire à a
pipièce.
OnOn fait le 3e lien ou par le e
lilien, c'est un mauvais...
- - Le débat sera présent, les
gegens vont se positionner et ça
dédépasse la région de Québec.
- - Je trouve que c'est une
trtragédie franchement.
CeCe qui devrait être un grand
prprojet collectif face l'objete
tatant de division, des chicane.
PlPlus je lis là-dessus, c'est
cocompliqué, ce n'est pas norma.
MiMichèle a raison pour Monsieur
DuDuhaime c'est un erreur, on ne
totouche pas à l'île d'Orléans.
JeJe veux parler d'un point dont
pepersonne ne parle, c'est une s
plplus belles villes du monde,
QuQuébec, l'aspect esthétique de
totout ça, l'aspect patrimonial,
ilil faut en parler un peu.
OnOn parle de milliards et des
grgros projets, mais je ne troue
quque ce n'est pas normal... il
fafaudrait qu'il y a un référenm
llà-dessus, on a passé des
foformations pour pouvoir prende
poposition là-dessus.
- - Émilie.
- - J'ajouterai, pour une fille
ququi vient de la ville de Lévi,
c'c'est... une des choses qui et
cocompliquée dans le dossier
dedepuis le début c'est la
ququestion de l'étalement urbain
etet comment ça empiète sur des
teterres agricoles qui sont dans
lala région.
C'C'est déjà un problème pour la
rérégion de Bellechasse.
SiSi on pense à un pont ou un
tutunnel dans l'île de Lévis, ms
avavec les propositions du parti
coconservateur, on rajoute
ququestion la, qui n'est pas
ququelque chose qui est souhaité
sisi j'ai bien compris par les
gegens de l'île d'Orléans même.
OnOn a un désavantage stratégiqe
alalors qu'il y a beaucoup de gs
hahalévy qui poussent, alors que
leles gens de l'île de Lorient e
sosont pas le derrière.
IlIl faudrait regarder peut-être
trtrès majeurs.
LeLe parti libéral du Québec
auaujourd'hui, avait aussi un
enengagement, Madame Anglade est
rerevenue sur son engagement de
dodonner un médecin de famille
PaParti québécois, d'ici 2030.
AfAfin d'accroître les noms
d'd'étudiants en médecine, on le
vovoit, on change de sujet.
LaLa santé, ça reste élection
apaprès élection.
ToTour de table.
ChChristian je commence à vous.
LaLa santé demeure un enjeu
imimportant.
- - C'est vrai surtout après la
papandémie.
LaLa crédibilité des promesses s
papartis politiques est à peu ps
nunulle dans ce domaine.
QuQuand on entend Madame Anglade
nonous dire : faudrait que touts
memes Québécois et un médecin de
fafamille.
C'C'est merveilleux, tout le moe
lele voudrait, mais quelle
crcrédibilité ces politiciens là
onont-ils?
CÇa fait depuis 15 ans qui nous
didit ça et la situation a
totoujours empiré.
JeJe pense que les gens veulent
dedes résultats et les promesses
dadans le thème de la santé...
j'j'espère qu'on va parler du
frfrançais.
JeJean-Luc bien sûr qu'on a par.
J'J'ai peur qu'on n'en parle pa.
DoDonc la santé, c'est méga
imimportant, mais ce qu'on veut
c'c'est que le gouvernement esse
dede changer le système pour que
çaça s'améliore.
OnOn n'y croit pas beaucoup,
MaMadame Anglade, c'est bien beu
unun médecin de famille pour
chchaque Québécois, mais on pase
unun autre chapitre.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe,
PaParti libéral du Québec
- - D'abord, le nombre de
mémédecins. Il va falloir qu'one
didise qu'on n'a pas suffisammet
dede médecins et qu'il va fallor
ququ'on augmente le nombre.
OnOn va augmenter de 1000 médecs
dudurant les 5 prochaines année.
101000 médecins. Et ça, ça va
fafaire en sorte que les gens vt
popouvoir au moins se dire qu'il
y y aura la possibilité d'avoir
acaccès à un médecin de famille.
- - Émilie, mais celle-ci,
d'd'abord.
- - Ça prend plus que cinq
ininformaient un médecin
prpremièrement.
ChChristian raison, c'est commee
pepetit garçon qui crie au loup,
pepersonne le cru parce que le
loloup est arrivé.
ToTout le monde a promit cette
afaffaire-là.
JeJe me souviens à l'époque où
MaMartin à côté la milice de la
sasanté disait : pour réduire le
mamanque de médecins, le médecin
réréduit sa demande, sinon mon
inintro.
ToToutes les cas de figure, et
c'c'est pour ça que Madame Angle
a a peut-être raison qu'elle va
réréussir à le faire, moi j'en
dodoute.
ToTout a pas mal été essayé et a
papas encore fonctionné.
- - Émilie, conclusions sur les
mémédecins.
- - Conclusions, Madame Angladea
paparlé des médecins, on parlait
dedes infirmières, j'ai pas
l'l'impression qu'on va régler e
cacas des conditions de travail
sosont beaucoup plus attractives
dadans le secteur privé.
IlIl y a une hémorragie.
OnOn s'appuie de plus en plus sr
lele secteur privé pour combler
leles trous dans le secteur
pupublic.
OnOn est dans un trou.
C'C'est sur cette question que
j'j'ai envie qu'elle est partie
papartie politique se penche
dudurant la campagne.
- -